in our series vaccinating america we're
looking at how a new strain of
coronavirus might affect vaccine
development and distribution
hhs secretary azar joins us this morning
good morning to you
good morning thanks for having me i want
to talk about that distribution
yesterday we had new jersey governor
murphy on saying that states really need
more help but we know that new jersey
along with california and several other
states
are having problems saying they didn't
receive as much vaccine as they thought
they would
what are you doing to ensure that these
states are getting the vaccines
oh for goodness sake and i was just with
governor murphy yesterday on the vice
president's governor's call there's not
an issue
we put out some initial estimates back
in november that were just broad
estimates to help with planning
assumptions
and then we gave each week on tuesday
night we give them the concrete
allocation of vaccines that they have to
be able to distribute within their state
uh this week for instance it's two
million doses of pfizer vaccine and 5.9
million doses of moderna vaccine
that's all clear the governors just need
to listen to the information we're
giving them
we've been very clear about that they're
allocating that and they're getting it
distributed out there and
i'm going to get the modern a vaccine in
just about an hour
yeah i want to ask you about that
because you're getting the moderna
vaccine we know that
joe biden president-elect got the
vaccine yesterday
dr anthony fauci getting the vaccine as
well today i have a number of people
in my circle who are healthcare
providers and i know that there have
been elected officials on both sides of
the aisle
who have really taken a lot of criticism
for getting the vaccine what do you have
to say to health care workers who say
well it's great that we're showing that
this is effective and these people are
getting the vaccine but i haven't gotten
mine yet
well for me for dr fauci for dr francis
collins of the nih and for
others out there as leaders it's really
important that we demonstrate our
confidence in the vaccine because
we've seen a surge in vaccine confidence
now over 80 percent of americans say
they would take the vaccine and that's
incredible improvement
literally the vaccines are approved
under my name
i committed early on that i would get
vaccinated publicly on tv
to demonstrate my complete and utter
confidence in the independence
of the fda's approval process of safe
and effective vaccines and that's what
i'm doing
and i encourage other leaders to do that
to again demonstrate confidence and
especially
we want to make sure we get other
thought leaders and individuals that
that will really help convey in in
underrepresented underserved communities
the need and importance of getting
vaccinated also are you privately urging
the president to take the vaccine on
camera
well i'm not going to discuss my
interactions with the president but the
president of course
he just has recovered from kovid he had
monoclonal antibodies
and he's going to have interactions with
his physicians about what's appropriate
he has tweeted
that he will get vaccinated and so i
think that's an important thing for
people to know
do you think he should get vaccinated i
think everybody should get vaccinated
that for whom it's indicated but it
needs to be at the right but it needs to
be at the right time and in consultation
with your health care providers
and people on the outside should be very
careful we don't want to get into the
business now
vaccine shaming individuals because we
don't know their interactions with their
physicians and the advice that they're
getting from their physicians
well so along what you said if someone
already had covid and has the antibodies
should they be discussing it with their
doctor and being cautious like the
president is
you should discuss that with your doctor
yes because you want to make sure if
you've
gotten the monoclonal antibodies you
want to make sure your physician has
assessed whether enough time has passed
that it's appropriate to get vaccinated
dr fauci has talked about this publicly
that it is appropriate to be vaccinated
after having recovered from coronavirus
and after having gotten
monoclonal antibodies but you'll just
want to make sure a sufficient amount of
time has passed in consultation with
your physician
you have an aggressive plan 100 million
doses you hope
go out by february i know a lot of
people who are saying
i do want to take the vaccine which i
think goes into your 80
category but they're saying i don't want
to take it right away i don't
download software at 1.0 i downloaded at
1.6 1.8
what do you have to say to those people
well we've seen
incredible uptake just in the first week
and a half of this program
every hospital that i've been to the the
healthcare workers it's oversubscribed
that people want to get vaccinated this
vaccine these two vaccines they're not
going to be sitting on shelves
and i think for all of those people you
referred to as they see
friends and neighbors and especially
healthcare workers getting vaccinated
and having positive experiences with it
i think it'll only continue to build
confidence you know it's that word of
mouth that
with with all things uh helps build
confidence in us
secretary azar thank you for joining us
thank you very much for having me